okay hello and good morning everyone
so I'm Mike Anderson and today I'm going
to be talking about convergent consensus
which is a key thing that we're doing as
part of our work at the convex
Foundation
but I want to start by going back to the
beginning
so I learned to code on an 8-bit
computer
the Atari 800 XL maybe some of you have
seen some of these
um it had a Motorola 6502 processor and
it was fantastic
there were no threads
you were
certainly didn't have to worry about any
networking you were in control of the
whole universe it was fantastic even the
only thing that caused interrupts was
that annoying human user
but of course everything goes wrong
people started venting multi-processing
multi-core processors we see the growth
of the internet suddenly you're dealing
with concurrent processes everywhere
with distributed systems you have to
deal with locking you have to be deal
with the consensus
it's complicated and I certainly never
thought I'd be standing up here talking
about consensus algorithms but I was
interested in something
when you see this world the internet
that we use we're still very much in
control of our own systems whether
that's our own PC or servers or even
server Farms that are under the control
of a large organization
they're still centralized computers in a
way where you are in control of your
little part of the universe so I was
interested well is it possible to build
a decentralized computer this is a a
public computer an open computer that
everyone can use and it actually should
feel more like part of the internet than
a typical traditional computer
so here's the requirements we want to
talk about we want to be able to execute
transactions on an open network
we want it to have decentralized
consensus so we do want it to agree we
want it to be consistent and to agree on
values
but we want that to be decentralized
there's no single entity or organization
that can determine the state of the
network or the outcome of transactions
we also want it to be fully programmable
we want it to be too incomplete we want
to be able to execute arbitrary code
of course we're running this on the
internet it has to be secure it has to
be fault tolerant people are going to be
malicious they're going to try and break
it and things are going to go on
and of course we like it to be efficient
and fast at the end of all of this or at
least I'd like it to be faster than my
800 XL
so it turns out and this is a quick
aside there is in fact an incredibly
elegant consensus algorithm that I
completely fell in love with what I saw
it and
it is decentralized and you only need
one function and let's take the max
function this is a standard maximum
value of two numbers you take the
largest of two integers
and if you take a function like this and
you give it to all of the different
nodes in your decentralized network
so let's say we have six peers a b c d f
and we give them each a number one two
three four five six and what we're going
to do is we're going to say okay in each
round what you're going to do is Gossip
your transaction to some random other
peers share your value and when you
receive a value from someone else you're
just going to put it through the max
function and your new value is going to
be the result of of that that
application
and you do this repeatedly over a few
rounds and something magic happens we
converge to the same value we actually
converge very quickly it's almost like a
you know a virus spreading exponentially
through the network it just fills up the
whole network and you get to this this
single consensus value and this is what
we call a conflict-free replicated data
type
and they are really really nice the
processes can basically they can do
their own stuff pretty much
independently without coordination you
don't need any messaging you don't need
any locks
simple random gossip networking is okay
so it doesn't matter if you lose some
temporary network connections or you
don't talk to everyone it recovers from
these kind of these kind of temporary
failures very well
and it's also secure against tampering
with one Proviso you have to be able to
reject a bad value
yeah so if someone puts a million in
your system you have to have a way of
knowing that that a million is a bad
value otherwise it's going to mess up
your consensus but as long as you can do
that it's actually it's actually pretty
secure and it is guaranteed to converge
to consensus at least in the terms of
eventual consistency
um and this has been well studied and uh
it's it's what you need in order to make
this crdt work is you need a merge
function and it's got to have three
three properties it's got to be
commutative so you can swap the order of
arguments it's got to be associative I I
like to think about this as you can put
the brackets wherever you like in your
in your calculation and it's got to be
ident if you merge the same value you're
going to get the same result
and if you have a data type an emerge
function that satisfies these conditions
you basically get a mathematical
structure called a join semilattis
and that's all you need for crdt to work
and you can prove this and you've got
all the nice properties as soon as you
can do that
so some examples you could have a grow
only counter so you can have a value
that grows according to the maximum of
two numbers
you can have a a set a set that grows
and here sets are merged using the set
Union function
and you can have some more complicated
things like a last white wins element
set so where the membership you can
insert or delete elements and the status
of an element is determined by the most
recent uh deletion or insertion
and people have built some pretty big
systems using these crdts because they
are so nice this includes things like
redis distributed databases distributed
hash tables can make good use of this
kind of technique
but of course we want to build a
computer so ideally we want Universal
State transitions we want to be able to
have some state of the computer we want
to bring along a block of transactions
instructions if you like and we want to
run that through some process and get
the new Global State and with the right
transition function we can make this
chewing complete we can support any kind
of calculations and computations as we
like
and
this obviously you can apply repeatedly
so you can if you have a sequence of
blocks you can repeatably apply the
state transition and
the nice thing about this is
as long as your state transition
function is deterministic I.E it's a
pure function there's no Randomness and
everyone's going to agree the way that
the computation happens
then if you get consensus over orderings
then you're going to get consensus over
the final State at the end of those at
the end of those blocks and everyone
will compute the same value and that's
exactly what we want for our
decentralized computer we want consensus
over the state of the computer after an
agreed set of blocks has been has been
processed
so this is what we're shooting for
unfortunately most transactions are not
going to be conflict-free
and this basically causes a problem and
let's take an example let's say you're
running a voting system so everyone gets
a vote
each person may cast only one vote and
once they've voted they can't change
their vote that's just fixed fixed
forever so it's a very simple process
the kind of thing you might Implement in
a decentralized application
but the problem is the ordering of
transactions causes different results if
you're voting for A and B it matters
which vote gets submitted first if
you're a vote for a first and that's the
final answer and it's never going to
change and this problem is sometimes
also referred as the double spend
problem because if you think this is
academic it really matters yeah it
really matters if you're paying two
people whether your money goes to person
a or the money goes to person B and
plenty of money has been lost this way
so one solution to getting a consensus
over and ordering is blockchain so I
won't go too much into the details of
how blockchain works I'm sure many of
you have seen some of this and there's
plenty of good material on the web but
briefly we're going to group a bunch of
signed transactions in blocks
each block is going to have a hash of
the data within that block and the next
block is going to contain within its own
data a pointer to the previous block so
effectively building a linked list that
is connected by these cryptographic
hashes
now in order for a block to be
considered valid
it needs to start with a number of zeros
and that's actually a hard problem
finding a hash that starts with a lot of
zeros the only way you can effectively
do it is by Computing a lot of hashes
this is the proof of work part of the
system and
the only reason anyone's willing to do
all of that work is of course there's a
reward if someone actually does all of
these hashes then they get to be the
creator of the next block and they get a
reward in Bitcoin for doing that
and the consensus album is really
longest chain wins
um so whichever is the longest chain
that someone's managed to build is
considered the best chain and consensus
has only really maintained by economics
it's not that you couldn't produce
another chain but doing so would be
unfeasibly expensive because of all of
the hashing you'd have to do to create a
new longer chain so the incentive is for
anyone who tried to build the next block
to build on top of the previous chain
so you get consensus just by weight of
economics
um now this is just not a great solution
one of the problems with this is of
course you're doing all of this hashing
this is not useful hashing you're not
Computing something useful you're just
doing it in order to uh win the right to
create the next block and of course that
creates incentives to spend a lot of
energy and a lot of computing Hardware
doing hashes and Bitcoin is now
certainly using more electricity than
many small companies
so it works it is decentralized and it
does it does in some way secure
consensus but it's not a great solution
and there's some other issues I mean you
can ask is it really decentralized
um well yes they're ethically but in
practice because of the amount of
hashing infrastructure and Hardware you
need to compute all these hashes it
actually ends up quite centralized among
a few large mining pools is it secure
well yes again theoretically but you do
have this problem but if someone is
temporarily able to get more than 51 of
the hashing power they can potentially
rewrite the chain and they can change
the ordering of blocks and they can
execute a double spend attack
and it's certainly not scalable you
couldn't run a you know a a real global
system on this you know it takes about
10 minutes per block on average
um about seven transactions per second
and because of this 51 risk you can't
simply take one block as a confirmation
you have to wait several blocks until
you're at least reasonably sure that
that's not going to change
so there must be a better way of of
solving this block ordering problem
so let's do a do a thought experiment
let's imagine and this isn't true but
let's imagine that you could see
simultaneously what every single Pier on
the network was thinking what they
thought the the consensus ordering was
um so here we've got Alice Bob Charlie
Dana and Elisa they're all thinking of
the same ordering of blocks from b0 to b
n minus one that's the current consensus
so we've got full visibility of the home
network
so let's imagine what happens if someone
wants to add a new block
well everyone can see this
so everyone can say well I've got no
better option for for the next block so
let's just adopt this block it might as
well
so everyone can copy that block and add
it to their own ordering
and then of course everyone can see this
so they can say well everyone's got the
same ordering that's beyond the Cohen
consensus so are we in agreement can we
propose this as a new consensus so they
all say yeah can we propose this
everyone looks around at each other says
yes we're all proposing the same thing
we're in agreement so let's let's Commit
This and let's move the consensus point
to now include the new the new block so
this confirmation of consensus when you
can see the whole world is essentially
as a two-phase commit yeah and that's
got a long pedigree and decentralized
algorithms I mean it's used in the
Practical Byzantine fault tolerance
algorithm very effectively so there's
two phrase commit can can basically get
you to a new consensus point
and it's also fairly fault tolerant so
let's say everyone agrees on a new block
if someone changes their mind and says
actually I don't like a I want BB well
everyone can see that that is
inconsistent with the consensus that
they've previously agreed so either
that's a faulty Pier or a malicious peer
doesn't really matter you can just
ignore them yeah they're not playing
your game so you just exclude them from
your from your future consideration
of course what happens if blocks
conflict now this is this is the very
important Point we've got multiple
candidates for what the next block is
going to be so
the secret here is to only look at the
next position so what is going to be the
proposed block for Block n
so we see that we've got a a
in two people and imagine you gave
everyone a vote and you can give the
weighted votes you can have a stake
weighted voting on this but let's say
you have a vote and AA is the one that
has the most votes
you're going to choose that
for the next position
as the preferred option that's becomes
your consideration set so only people
who have put a A in that position are
now under consideration so you reduce
the size of the consideration set from
everyone to only the people who proposed
AA for the next round you might move on
to the next position so what's a what's
in the next block well you've actually
only got one proposal here so you've
only got CC so again in this case simple
case you can say cc is going to be the
answer so we Define this as the winning
ordering yeah this is the best ordering
and everyone can see that this is the
winning ordering because they can order
the same computation
uh We've also got a new block an
additional block So that obviously can't
conflict with the winning ordering but
we can just put it after
a a and CC so we can just append any
extra miscellaneous blocks that other
people have proposed on the end
now everyone could do exactly the same
computation because they can all see the
whole world so they can all propose aacc
and BB
we now get the uh step of saying okay
this is now proposed consensus so
everyone's proposing the same thing are
we of all agreement
and we simultaneously say okay we commit
this
now this is really really nice because
what we're doing in one effective uh
round of consensus
we're doing simultaneous sorting and
confirmation of blocks so you could have
potentially hundreds or thousands of
blocks coming in simultaneously and
still confirm them all in one shot you
don't have to wait for previous blocks
to be confirmed you can do it all in
parallel and this is a pretty big win
um
now of course
this is an imaginary world yeah we don't
actually have a view on the entire
network but what we can do is we can
Define this thing called a belief
and the belief is a data structure and
we're going to have the most recent
orderings from each peer we have a
timestamp on each of those and we're
going to get each pair to sign their
ordering as part of this data structure
so that we can authenticate it and
verify it and it's effectively immutable
snapshot and the belief is really the
peers best understanding of the state of
the network consensus
according to the information it is
received so far that's the way to think
about it
and
we can now Define a merge function so
once we've defined these beliefs as a
data structure there's a natural merge
operation so whenever we merge two
beliefs for each peer in those two
beliefs we just take the most recent of
those two orderings according to this
time stamp and they're signed of course
so it's authenticated and we can exclude
anything invalid if someone puts it
invalid data or a bad signature we can
just kick that out
we then update our own ordering
according to the consensus rules so the
peer that's actually doing the merge at
the present time and they can then sign
it because they've got their own private
key so they can then update the belief
with a signed ordering now they can only
do it for themselves they can't
impersonate anyone else because each
peer has their own their own private
keys but they can sign their own part of
the belief and create a new a new belief
through this process
and this is this is basically the magic
we can now build a crdt and this
combined algorithm we call Convergent
proof of stake so it's really really
simple peers share these beliefs with
random gossip
they merge the beliefs that they receive
through the merge function
and then optionally if they have any new
novelty any new transactions they can
append new blocks to their own ordering
and then they just do it again they just
send out their new their their latest
belief to other peers and their crdt
happens and this creates consensus over
ordering as a crdt and we get all of
those lovely crdt properties that we
that we want to have
so this is great there's just one big
problem now of course most of you have
probably spotted this
we have a size problem so let's say you
have a thousand peers on the network
maybe 10 blocks a second maybe 20K data
each block
um you know that would be reasonable
expectation of a global scale network
but you're going to have a lot of
history these orderings are going to be
long you might have you know 500 million
blocks worth of transactions going back
going back a few years this becomes this
becomes pretty big and
um each belief might be about 100
petabytes on that scaling so this is not
going to work this is this is a lot of
Gossip to get over the network it's just
it's simply not going to scale so we
have to solve this problem
um we do it with data structures
so in particular we build the beliefs as
Merkle trees so a Merkel tree is a a
tree where each node contains the hashes
of its child nodes
so it's a bit like the blockchain except
the blockchain is just a Merkel tree
with only one very very long branch we
just build the whole data structure as a
as a Merkel tree and it's a pure
functional data structure and this has
some really nice properties it's order
one copy and it's order log n for read
and update so it's very efficient
computationally
and the login isn't so bad because we
have a moderate branching Factor so you
know tip maybe an average of five to ten
child nodes at each at each level
uh we obviously everything's done with
the cryptographic hash so a nice
property of Merkel trees is if you have
the hash of the top node then you can
verify the Integrity all the way down
the entire entire tree
um and it's a perfect fit for Content
dressable storage so the key is just the
hash of the content of each node and the
value is just the content and this is a
perfect fit for append only content to
decibel storage and systems like that
which is again very efficient
now once we've done this we can start
optimizing beliefs
so say we have our belief data structure
we have ordering for each peer well
we're going to notice that for example
Alice and Charlie they've they're
thinking of exactly the same set of
blocks the blocks that were previously
in consensus up to BN minus one
so in our storage and in our data
structures whether it's in memory or on
disk we can just de-duplicate we can say
let's just point at um let's just point
to that that same data structure
but we can go further than that
um if you think of this as a tree and we
can partition it in various different
ways
then in fact all of the peers are
sharing the same beliefs up to BN minus
one so we can just de-duplicate all of
that and this is going to be already a
pretty massive saving in size
and then there's going to be some things
in the new data so AA for example is
shared we can just deduplicate that so
we've already made a significant
reduction in the size of the data
structure it's still too big and the
problem is this massive long chain of
historical data yeah
um that's going to going to be going to
be a problem but we have a solution for
this as well because it's all immutable
and because peers have shared a Merkel
tree with the hashes we know that
they've already got that data because
they've already verified it we know that
they must already have the ordering
otherwise they couldn't have sent us a
belief that actually referred to that
ordering so we know they've already got
it in fact we know they've already got
most of it so all we need to do is
transmit and gossip the pieces of this
data structure which are novelty
and that might not even that might only
be two two new blocks yeah a a for
example they could have already shared
they already know that other peers have
been sharing that so that's not new BB
and CC is new so that's all that we need
to share and you can identify this
through your storage mechanism you can
tag things that you've previously seen
and when you try and look up in the
store if it's already if it's already
there it's not novelty if it's new then
it's novelty so you just transmit that
um so we only basically need to gossip
the newly observed blocks plus some
overhead the layers of the tree that
basically validate the Integrity of the
Merkel tree but that's a relatively
small proportion of of the data
um so this algorithm I think is actually
fairly close to Optimal first of all
it's Byzantine fault tolerant as long as
you allow for the sort of typical
assumptions that you know there's only a
minority of attackers like less than a
third of the network are faulty or
malicious
but it's basically as good as you can
get in a in a truly decentralized
Network where malicious nodes could
potentially join at any time
um it confirms transactions in as few as
three rounds of gossip
um which I I believe is also the
theoretical Optimum uh for for Byzantine
fault tolerance system
um and that's even allowing for some
internet latency that's probably going
to be less than one second
and remember that this confirmation can
be happening on many blocks at once
and peers because there's no there's no
limitation on peers adding blocks in
their own belief the zero block delay
they can just add a block whenever they
feel like it you don't have to wait and
there's no latency for adding new blocks
uh we do the simultaneous sorting and
confirmation of many blocks so we could
confirm a thousand blocks in one second
it's not a it's not a it's not a problem
and the communication overhead is is
obviously on in the in the size of the
number of transactions that you're
executing which is again is optimal I
mean that's genuine new novelty to the
system so you're going to have to
transmit that at some point and the
belief merge is actually very efficient
as well partly because we've
deduplicated the data structures so much
already but it's just not
computationally very expensive you can
certainly do belief merge in less than a
millisecond on on decent Hardware
uh so of course we actually want to do
stuff with this consensus algorithm so
this is the convex virtual machine
um so it is effectively taking these
blocks of transactions and updating a
global state so each instance of the CVM
has a global State we actually run it
single threaded
um
and now it could potentially be
paralyzed but it doesn't seem to be
necessary it's already very fast we get
about a million War transactions per
second locally we can do about a million
transactions per second and the reason
for that is again we've got very
efficient data structures so the update
of these Merkle trees can be very very
fast and
we also have the advantage of because
it's single threaded you don't have any
locking you don't have any any sort of
overhead of that of that kind of
accounting so it's just it's just a very
fairly lean and fast system
the structure of the global State and
it's a big data structure it has globals
so some parameters that sort of affect
the whole network that everyone would
want to be able to see has data about
the peers so peers can identify each
other and locate each other when they're
gossiping it has a thing called a
schedule which I won't go into too much
detail but it's basically a way of
putting transactions which get
automatically executed at a later date
the most important part by far is the
accounts and these are numbered accounts
with the idea that an account would
typically either be a user account owned
by a user or a autonomous actor account
which is like an independently running
program those accounts say would have a
a public key so you can verify
transactions that a user sends in for
that account
sequence number is just a tracking the
individual transactions so they don't
get out of order
controller is allows for delegated
management of an account
and a very interesting thing is the
environment so in each account we have
effectively a key Value Store where the
user can Define arbitrary values against
arbitrary symbols
uh within the context of their account
so you basically get a little database
with every with the account
and in fact it's a bit more than that
we get very rich data types so we have
all the kind of data types you typically
expect
um you know your booleans your Longs if
any of your closure users you might
recognize keywords
and then we have some high level data
types collections like sets two
mathematical sets Maps vectors and some
specialized ones so blobs if you want to
store binary data or an address which is
just a pointer effectively to an account
um and every account effectively can be
used as a lisp machine
um so you can have a full interactive
weapon experience it's programmable
um some little examples you could like
say what's my address get your own
address you can do computation numerical
computations you can Define values
within your own environment you can
update your own environment
you can do data structure operations so
konj Foo 4 is adding a value to the end
of the end of a vector
it's very similar to closure style
syntax the CVM is actually language
agnostic you could compile anything any
kind of front-end language to it I
happen to like closure so we we
implemented convex convex lisp first but
it's just it's a it's a very flexible
high level uh language based on First
cast functions so full Lambda calculus
it's got automatic garbage collection it
has an on-chain compiler which is quite
unique so you can actually compile
programs in the decentralized context if
you want to an example of that would be
an actor which is able to generate new
actors So within the context of the
decentralized smart contract or an actor
you can actually generate new new
instances of actors so self-replicating
code is possible
um it has functional data structures so
all the data structures are a mutable
Merkle trees persistent data structures
rather similar to closure or Scala or
Haskell and we have macros so it's got a
you know a simple a simple macro system
somewhat inspired by uh scheme
so let's do a little example just for
fun so we mentioned vote counting this
will be a typical code for a a simple
actor so we're going to define a couple
of things first we're going to Define
um who has voted so far so we have a set
this is an empty set no one has voted at
the present time
um a second data structure is a map
we're going to say the the tally of
votes so we're going to have red green
and blue each initially with zero votes
and then we're going to have this this
function defining a function and the
function we have this special tag which
is callable
now what this means is this function
isn't just a regular function it's an
entry point to this actor so this is
something that people external users can
call in order to cast their vote and
they're going to provide one parameter
which is the color that they want to
vote for
So within the context of this anyone can
call this this is a callable function so
it's really important to check your
preconditions and any rules that you
want to enforce first so if someone
gives a color which is not in the valid
votes we want to fail I want to tell you
that's not a valid choice
if they've already voted so we check
whether the caller of the function is a
member of the voted set
if they are again we want to fail
they've already voted
if they pass those two criteria in this
case
we want to actually okay we want to
count the vote so we're going to update
the votes we're going to increment the
uh the votes for the color that they've
selected
and we also want to add them to the
voting set so that they can't vote again
so if they call this again it's going to
fail the second the second time and
finally we just return a return value
when it's when it's all uh it's when
it's all successful now everything in a
transaction is atomic so if anything
goes wrong at any point the entire thing
gets rolled back to the previous state
so you can never get left in an
inconsistent State now it's really nice
that we're using those Merkle trees I
said we can do order one copies
rollbacks are therefore essentially free
we can just go back to a previous copy
of the entire entire State even though
it's a very big data structure the copy
is is super cheap and we can just
restore it
and this will be autonomous so this is
not a user account this will just code
running and available for people to call
on the network and you could make it
updatable but you could also make it
frozen so that no one can possibly
update this code and it just continued
doing its job for all eternity in this
in this way
um
forever
so the usage from a user account well
you need to know what you want to call
so let's say the boat counter is an
actor which has the account one four
five four seven so we're just going to
you know Define that and then it's just
a case of calling it you just do a call
I want to call that particular actor and
I want to vote for red and it's going to
give me okay that was a success
if I then try and vote again I call the
vote counter and vote try and vote for
green it's going to fail it's going to
tell me I've already voted I'm wasting
my time ever trying to vote again
because I'm already in the voted set
um but what I can do is because it is a
global State and it's a true Global
state so I can query and I can look at
data anywhere in the global State it's
effectively public so I can look at the
votes data structure within the vote
counter and I can see what the current
the current tally is and that's again
effectively free it's just looking up a
value in the in a big in a big Merkle
tree data structure so it's really
really cheap we can actually potentially
support billions of queries per second
simply because it's so cheap to do
lookups in these kind of in these kind
of structures
now there is a little bit of necessary
economics in this system so we do have a
protocol defined digital currency which
you pay you can use to pay for
transactions the processing cost of
transactions and you can see it as a
utility token it's the right to execute
transactions now the intention is this
is super super cheap but we apply
congestion pricing if the network starts
to get near to capacity
now ideally we wouldn't have to do this
but there are two very practical reasons
why we need a transaction pricing
mechanism in this kind of system first
of all the peers are actually providing
real infrastructure it's maybe not
massive great hashing Farms but they're
still providing servers to one that run
the nodes and they're providing stake on
the network so we do need to give them
some reward for that just to make it
economically viable and we also want to
make denial of service attacks hard so
if you try and congest the network
transactions are going to get very
expensive and it becomes economically
infeasible to maintain a denial of
service attack for very long yeah you
can try it temporarily but it soon
becomes too expensive for you to be able
to continue
we also do something quite interesting
with memory accounting So This Global
state
can be very big it can be certainly be
you know terabytes terabytes in size
because you can it's all you know paged
out to disk but it is still a shared
resource it is still a a global a global
constraint that every peer needs to
maintain
so we actually do accounting on memory
size and the accounting is done based on
the size of State changes so if you
increase the size of the global State
you have to pay uh to actually buy that
extra memory
but the good thing is because of this
accounting you can also give refunds if
you deallocate memory so we actually
create a really nice economic incentive
for people to write memory efficient
code so in fact some of those skills you
might have learned coding machine code
on a Atari 800 XL might actually be
useful after all
and because we're doing this Merkle tree
it actually turns out it's quite cheap
to do this memory accounting because you
can just store the data size alongside
the nodes in the Merkel tree
so what are the implications of this
whole setup well we we do get real time
or at least very near real-time
performance for decentralized computing
so if you want to get interactive
performance if you're trying to build a
metaverse if you're trying to build
something where you want users to get
great responsiveness this is a great
approach
it allows you to build stateful apps
without servers you can put the key
elements of your application State on a
decentralized network that's not going
to work for everything I wouldn't
recommend it for all applications but
some aspects of State you may want to
put on a decentralized system like this
it allows I think and I think this is
very interesting it allows for
self-sovering peer-to-peer interactions
so people can interact with each other
directly without going through any
centralized servers and it is open it is
inclusive it's somewhere where everyone
can participate on a Level Playing Field
it does allow for these autonomous
actors actors and smart contracts which
you can see as providing essential
functionality or keeping track of votes
running shared Registries there's a lot
of different potential applications for
those and it could even go so far as
building entire virtual organizations so
these decentralized autonomous
organizations that effectively run just
by smart contracts and different people
can interact with those smart contracts
as they choose
and a matter which is extremely close to
my heart this entire setup is extremely
energy efficient there's no wasted
energy
um and it's therefore a good sustainable
solution if you want to be able to run
this at a internet scale
um so that's pretty much the end of what
I wanted to uh cover
um I would say that we are an open
source project we're a non-profit
Foundation Building this technology and
would very much welcome collaborators
who want to get involved we can visit
our website we have a we have a Discord
where a lot of discussions happen both
on the sort of you know the technical
and the philosophical side and of course
the codes are all available on uh on
GitHub for everyone wants to dive in and
get involved with that
so thank you all for listening very
happy to take any any questions if we
have any time left
foreign
million transactions per second is about
how many transactions you can pump
through in memory on a local CVM yeah so
we probably wouldn't expect you to be
able to get that on a full-scale network
the CVM itself can handle that but
you're probably at that scale you're
going to hit bottlenecks on networking
and you're probably also at that scale
going to hit bottlenecks on digital
signature verification so it's unlikely
we'd be able to get that in a full
Global Network we're still doing a lot
of testing of testing on that
random access to State queries that can
be billions because that is that is one
of those embarrassingly parallel
problems you can have 50 peers with
replicas of the global State and they
can each serve read-only queries
independently so you can do read-only
transactions effectively at web scale
um so that it's only if you want to
write and change the global state that
you hit the bottleneck yep
foreign
okay so the
um a couple of things to break down
um I mean it's not technically a
blockchain the blocks aren't actually
linked to each other so it's not really
a chain of blocks it's more like a an
ordering of blocks once you've got the
consensus up to a certain point
the peers have the track of the global
State and if they confirm
new blocks in consensus they then run
the computation to update the global
state to catch up with the latest
consensus so that could be a separate
process or a separate machine from the
um the computation of the consensus
itself so the consensus just gets you
the ordering and then the virtual
machine is then running the computation
to catch up with the consensus state to
get you your your latest version of the
global state but that can be done
separately practically we do it on the
same machine
um and book posts it's probably faster
to do it that way than to try and pipe
the uh
um the transactions to to a separate to
a separate machine it's possible maybe
we you could you could scale it that's
actually an implementation choice though
it doesn't affect the protocol so how
you decide to do your uh your
computation locally doesn't change how
the consensus gets agreed so there's
various different options there
but yeah currently it's a it's a
different thread in the same jvm
instance on the same on the same machine
for that
okay that that makes sense so I'll take
the second one first actually is it
cheap to confirm consensus yes that's
very cheap because the global state is a
big Merkel tree you can in fact say the
state the hash of the state the top hash
you just need to confirm that you've got
the same the same state hashes as as
other people in the network and you can
confirm that that con that the outcome
at least of those transactions everyone
has come to the same result so that's
that's that's very efficient
the question about the finality probably
should have a separate conversation
afterwards
um and I'm not an academic expert on
consensus algorithms my belief is it is
basically as good as other
um Byzantine fault tolerance systems so
effectively similar to pbft it's similar
in the sense of a two-phase commit and
the finality
as long as you've got enough good nodes
agreeing on consensus that can never be
reversed because they're never going to
change their mind yeah so that they're
never going to uh they're never going to
switch once once it's once it's once
it's reached a certain threshold so
um it's it's final once you've reached
that point
all right thank you very much love to
continue the conversation after